- If you like pizza, and you enjoy pizza,
and you eat pizza, the
likelihood is extremely high
that you have seen our pizza boxes.
My name is Gil Korine, and I
make pizza boxes for a living.
We roughly make 10 million boxes a week.
As far as the design is concerned,
it's very particular.
You know, picture of a pizza box,
kind of like an album used to be.
It kind of creates what
the artist is all about,
and that's what, you know, these owners
view their pizza boxes as.
- I've probably done
over 10 thousand designs.
This is a Holly original,
and it's everywhere.
I see it in the garbage pails,
I see it on the side of the parkway,
I see it at friend’s houses
when they get pizza.
The fact that so many people,
literally millions of people
have seen my work and
don't know that it's me,
kinda makes me chuckle
to myself (chuckles)
like I'm somehow sneaking through life
with this identity that no one knows.
- Having started the
business from the beginning,
the one thing about pizza, it
brings happiness to everybody.
Everyone loves pizza.
(upbeat music)